dans la capitale ukrainienne clovis
casali bonjour à vous clovis vous êtes
la place maïdan est-ce que la riposte
s'organise est ce que les choses ont
évolué ce matin quelles sont les
informations dont vous disposez
forcément le pouvoir ukrainien est en
train d'organiser la riposte on le voit
pas ici bien sûr dans le coeur de kiev à
meydan ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que depuis l'aube même un petit peu
avant l'aube qu'elle nous on s'est
réveillé à 6 heures du matin au son des
explosions au loin ici à kiev pas dans
la capitale mais aux alentours à environ
34 à km d'ici il y à l'aéroport à
principale de kiev et selon des
témoignages là-bas et bien des
installations ont été bombardés par les
russes on a entendu donc des explosions
pendant une bonne partie de la matinée
depuis une heure ou un peu plus d'une
heure eh bien on n'entend plus
d'explosions on a vu de la fumée plus
tôt ce matin ici à kiev c'est un mélange
d'inquiétude et d'amertume
d'incompréhension chez les gens on a
parlé avec des ukrainiens qui se
promenaient faut dire que les rues ici
dans le centre-ville sont assez vide
très peu de gens assez peu de
circulation avec des voitures de police
et des militaires la déployer dans le
centre-ville assez peu de gens le ppe-de
ukrainien qui nous avons pu parler nous
disent qu'ils n'y croient pas ils ne
peuvent pas croire que vladimir poutine
a donc ordonné cette offensive de grande
ampleur semble-t-il contre l'ukraine
cette invasion semble-t-il de l'ukraine
de l'incompréhension de l'amertume un
réveil très douloureux pour les
ukrainiens selon certains ukrainien qui
j'ai pu parler qui essayait de quitter à
kiev eh bien ils n'ont pas pu quitter la
capitale des ukrainiens des ukrainiennes
qui cherchaient à fuir avec leurs
familles et qui ont dû rebrousser chemin
il semblerait aussi que les stations
essence soient vides ce qui rend très
compliqué tout départ de même que pour
les banques dont vous imaginez cette
opération russe en ukraine et bien a des
conséquences immédiates ici à kiev où
c'est l'inquiétude et où le pouvoir bien
évidemment est en train est à pied
d'oeuvre et a déjà commencé ces derniers
jours c dernières semaines car cette
invasion n'est pas une surprise personne
ne voulait y croit hier le pentagone a
une fois de plus déclaré qu'une invasion
et est imminente que vladimir poutine
contre toute attente malgré ce qu'il
avait pu dire ces derniers temps étaient
prêts à agir et c'est fait il envoyait
ses troupes russes
clovis le président ukrainien il a
appelé ses concitoyens à ne pas paniquer
dans un message vidéo qui a été diffusée
sur son compte facebook qui dit pas de
panique nous sommes prêts pour tous nous
allons vaincre est-ce que l'armée
ukrainienne et étaient prêtes étaient
prêtes sachant que l avait annoncé
d'ailleurs quelques elle avait mobilisé
ces derniers jours ses réservistes
en tout cas l'armée ukrainienne était
sur le qui vive et oui le président
ukrainien volodimir lln ce qui s'est
adressé à la nation un message fort un
message de mobilisation
nous vaincrons à il a essayé bien sûr de
faire en sorte que le moral de la
population du peuple reste intacte ce
qui est forcément être très compliqué le
président zelensky qui appelle aussi à
une coalition anti poutine si vous
voulez en tout cas il
s'est entretenu avec des chefs d'état du
monde entier ces derniers jours avec la
france mais aussi avec les états unis le
royaume uni l'allemagne il souhaite une
coalition anti poutine pour essayer
d'obtenir cette paix même si ça semble
un peu tard mais il dit qu'il est encore
temps de faire en sorte de mettre la
pression sur la russie pour qu'elle
arrête ses opérations dans le pays je
laisserai nos envoyés spéciaux déployer
un petit peu partout en ukraine et aussi
à la frontière russe vous en dire plus
sur l'avancée de ces opérations car
c'est très difficile depuis qui rêve de
le faire mais on a des témoignages un
peu partout des gens à qui on parle des
gens sur les réseaux sociaux qui parle
d' attaques de bombardements dans
plusieurs grandes villes du pays sur
plusieurs fronts difficile à vérifier
en tout cas ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que à kiev même on entendait à des
explosions notamment aux alentours de
l'aéroport qui à seulement 30 kilomètres
d'ici le pouvoir ukrainien le
gouvernement qui a fermé l'espace aérien
on peut imaginer aussi que 1 l'envi la
volonté les opérations russes les russes
qui disent qu'ils ont a détruit les
batteries anti-aériennes les armes pour
empêcher ces opérations eh bien les
russes qui crie déjà victoire et c'est
peut-être aussi une manière pour eux en
détruisant ses installations anti
aériennes dont péché l'approvisionnement
de l'ukraine d'empêcher à des puissances
étrangères de faire venir ici des armes
pour renforcer les ukrainiens qui se
trouve aux prises avec les russes mais
lenski le président ukrainien qui a
déclaré la loi martiale hier c'était
l'état d'urgence qu'est ce que ça veut
dire et bien déjà les réservistes ne
peuvent pas quitter l'ukraine des
réservistes qui sont déjà mobilisés pas
forcément pour aller au front mais au
moins prêts à s'engager prêt à partir si
besoin est et aussi pour faire en sorte
que miens le pays continue de vivre de
manière ordonnée c'est aussi un point
essentiel pour l'ukraine l'économie qui
peut être fortement touchée ça c'est une
volonté du pouvoir ukrainien d'essayer
de faire en sorte que les affaires
courantes à puce est expédié si vous
voulez ou en tout cas que le pays puisse
fonctionner malgré ces opérations
militaires russes
merci